foreign
[Music]
whatever
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
what's going on guys welcome to another
r r with the Lord's
um
we got pretty much a standard thing
going on with zoom
the
our other thing wasn't really working
that well it's like blinking and I
wasn't gonna risk like putting it on
there so far so we'll just do this we do
have some announcements that we're going
to make it in terms of the show
but uh right now you know we don't
really got to talk about any of that so
welcome to the r r toys we talk about
entertainment TV shows and Anime what's
going on King
I am doing fantastic sir if I knew that
we were going to be uh this broad I need
to turn the lights on my shelves I'll be
right back give me a second okay
all right there we go
it's good now
so what what
um
we got some stuff for you guys man we
got some stuff for you
we we
have been gone for a week you know I was
going through some stuff but now we are
back we got some uh
obviously you guys see the uh the the
topics you know we see it a little bit
we've watched a little bit today but
anyway you know we we first thing I want
to talk about King is I want to talk
about Attack on Titan recap you know you
have officially watched the first season
and you're relatively far into the
second season you know we're going to
start the reactions back up probably
here in the next couple days
um I am gonna probably know life the
Demon Slayer because I've been meaning
to get to it I've just been so busy you
said a thing I sent you right yeah yeah
so um it's hilarious what is your
opinions on the first season of Attack
on Titan
well let's start off slow I didn't know
what to expect you know being that this
is a highly touted uh highly coveted
anime you know um
I really yo I really picked people early
on
that either fell off or died or or too
weak
and I I thought those characters was
going to be something phenomenal and
they set you up in a way that they make
you or they or they guide you in a way
to liken certain characters and thinking
those those characters are going to be a
force of Nature and um
that's not true
you know you find out very early on
these guys got issues uh there's people
that's not who they're supposed to be or
um
it's just so much Espionage going on
Behind These Walls
and it's you don't know who's who and
what's what and everybody has secrets
and the people that you think are on the
level aren't it's it's one of the most
enticing uh animes that I've ever
watched it has so many layers to it just
like you know uh how they have so many
layers to the walls are you know the
inner wall the outer wall and all this
Rose wall and all this other stuff so
this whoever sat there and thought about
this thing man
um they set it up perfectly
you know so the first season
did it live up to the expectations that
I had for because you guys set it up
there really lofty it kind of
underperformed my expectations
now that's not to say that season two
didn't right now is at the middle of
over achieving you know making up for
that and then I don't even know how you
suffered you said you suffered some
years waiting for season two to show up
from season one it was like two years
maybe three
yeah
so and I guess that's that really had a
lot to do with the writing of it right
like which direction it was going to go
they probably had to go intricately into
every episode and
see where they hid certain characters
where certain characters could uh come
back and you know uh how they can fool
you and triple change stuff so it
probably had a lot to do with the
writing of where they was going to take
the uh the seasons next because I'm
gonna tell you
that last episode where uh that Titan
that she encased herself in that Amber
oh man it was kind of crazy and um
to find out who she was
and she was not gonna go underground and
she just did fall for the traps and then
we she had a whole little blade system
that she used to activate her Titan
abilities
oh man it was it was a real fun ride you
know so like I said it underperforms
slightly to the expectations because you
guys are talking about top tier uh anime
top number one or number two anime in
the world to you
and to me it it's it's it's close you
know um like again I told you I'm that
one-on-one combat dude so when they do
have those fights it's like wow it's
like Boombastic right so and I like
those one-on-one fights so yeah I would
say that's what I like there wasn't a
lot of one-on-one fights between like
Titans in the first season but they
reminiscent people yeah there's times
Aarons fight multiple Titans so yeah
well when I when I got a chance to see
uh you know um Levi versus the female
Titan and I got a chance to see
that was probably the highlight of the
first one yeah
when you finally see that Levi ain't all
talk like no he's about that life yeah
and what's crazy is like you see a lot
more from him uh right now he's injured
in season two a lot of season two so he
doesn't really uh do a whole lot but
I would say season you'll see a little
bit of him towards the end of season two
but for the most part you see he comes
back full force in season one I mean
season three and he's pretty much there
for the remaining of season three he's
injured you know mainly the most most of
the time yeah so
um keep in mind guys if you guys want to
see a lot of King's reactions to that
you know all you have to do is go to the
patreon it's right there just put it in
the uh
the majority of season ones up there
because he got to about I think it was
like two or three episodes before the
female Titan and Levi and all that's
been is up there and a good amount of
season two like I think we only got like
maybe two or three episodes left don't
forget oh sorry go ahead and then he'll
be going on to season three uh he
actually reacted to the trailer for
season two as well
uh and then I'm going to probably no
live Demon Slayer here soon because I I
mentioned like every week it seems like
more and more crazy stuff's happening on
that show uh so I'm more I'm I'm
interested in uh seeing what that's
going on but we'll go ahead and uh what
was your second no I'm just gonna tell
everybody that everybody is here uh the
patreon has you know a whole lot to
offer and we're going to start uh
dumping uh car rap ton of content into
the patreon uh also
um the the console that we're going to
give away where we go we will be giving
it away to uh you know to the patreon so
um we're trying to have everybody engage
into the patreon and you know reward
everybody that way uh through the
patreon so
um that and you know those those people
that are in the patreon not saying that
everybody doesn't support the patreon
it's just like an extra level of support
so I feel that you know we should
definitely go the extra mile in that
support yeah and because we do put out
free content you know for uh for YouTube
you know for our subscribers but you
know the patreon people need to get a a
crap ton of benefit so you know console
yeah uh you know exclusive content like
the attack on Titan stuff yes and more
stuff you know like Demon Slayer what
you did chainsaw man and a whole bunch
of season or chainsaw man yeah uh so
you had me watch a movie man we're gonna
go ahead and Sega you do it it's it's
called mother yes uh so you know I I
want to hear your overall opinion on on
mother first so you know get give the
people the
the the debt the play-by-play when it
comes to Mother Jennifer Lopez you know
yeah so I'm not a huge fan of Jennifer
Lopez I'm right either I actually this
is one of her better movies I've ever
seen yeah which movie like shotgun
wedding a couple months ago yes and that
was horrible but I actually I didn't
like that movie but I actually uh I was
a lot more of a fan of this movie I I
almost didn't finish shotgun wedding I
actually finished this movie yeah this
movie sets up a lot of stuff so you have
you know goes from Power that's uh in
this movie and
the movie starts off with a great actor
yeah yeah he's a phenomenal actor I mean
he he was funny like every scene that he
was in with her he stole the scene
regardless of what even when he was dead
not moving he stole a scene
um
this uh yeah I'm sorry I suppose that
for you guys it's on Netflix
um
but uh this uh this movie
I I really don't like Jim and my wife is
a huge fan of Jennifer
oh God anything this lady does she gotta
do it and you know she sees herself as
like uh somebody go with Jennifer Lopez
so
I'm like okay let me watch this and
very early on I found out yo this movie
is going to turn into the last of us
like season two at some point in time
but um she's like this ex-military
sniper
that dated these arms dealers that had a
conflict and uh
she happens to get pregnant but she
wants to turn and form it to turn these
dudes over to the government and these
dudes are some of the most badass dudes
on the planet and she's involved and
intertwined with these guys and you
don't know who's the daddy to this baby
but what's funny is they never tell you
yeah man
they're trying to they're trying to kill
her they're trying to kill her and I
think the reason why I like this film
more than all her other films even the
one where she was the abused wife that
she took revenge on her ex-husband and
and I can equate that movie closer to
this one
she's really GI Jane she's hard knows
her body looks phenomenal she's in
phenomenal shape for her age
she is and that's not age shaming you
know I'm not in phenomenal shape for my
age but this woman here she's taking the
time that she uh has is afforded uh with
the luxury that she has and she has
fine-tuned her body and it made this
movie more believable because of the
shape this woman is in she is in
CrossFit shape like phenomenal shape and
I'm not talking about you know from a
guy Googling oogling you know type of
[__] I'm talking about
bro she like the serrations in her back
when she's leaning over the edge talking
to to the guy at one of the ballroom
scenes I'm like this woman is a monster
an absolute monster in the gym I know
she does everything for her body her
body makes her money her money is there
and it's being shown so
it made it more believable with the
stuff that they was asking her to do as
far as being in sharpshoot as far as
being as ruthless as she was you can
tell that in terms of the movie that's
where she was comfortable all behind
that sniper rifle like because they had
her behind that sniper rifle multiple
times in the movie like yeah and if you
notice the biggest thing
she taught the individual is to shoot
like she she taught her what what her
trade is
she ain't no slouch when it comes to
fighting like she could do that but you
could tell that what I like about this
is the realization that she's a woman
yeah she knows that she's going to come
across bigger people because if you
notice when she when she's training her
she says that multiple times
if you got a knife you're up close
they're most likely he's going to be
bigger than you you don't stop until he
can't can't keep going exactly and you
keep on hitting you keep on striking
what I didn't like about the film did
you ever notice when they had the
one-on-ones like they'd do this tunnel
vision type of camera that blurs the
outside lenses like and you can only
focus on what's what what what what the
film the camera is having you focus on
hated that and it did that multiple
times
I thought that was a a failure on the
director's part
to show that butt at the same time this
is a movie about a female sniper who's
in the top two percent of her class so
that gives you the whole sniper type of
scope that he was trying to intertwine
into the film
which it felt kind of flat for me but I
understand the premise behind it so the
thought process is give them that sniper
type of Scope when you have these
meaningful moments and I thought it
actually took away from the moments
because the blur effect was a little bit
too much but um again the film was
really good to for me it's one of her
best films in my opinion uh what how did
you feel about it I liked it I thought
it was uh at first I was kind of iffy
because I saw her in it and I'm not the
biggest fan of Jennifer Lopez yeah but
after I started watching it um man I
can't remember uh enough in that the
other movie she was in that you were
referring to yeah
this movie just completely shits on that
movie yeah it's it's it's so good
because what I like about her is like in
this movie is
they never you could tell that she was
an expert in things
but they always made it realistic in a
real life situation like she wasn't in
there fighting 20 30 people like did you
notice that when her and the dude from
ghosts invaded that place he's the one
that was on foot in there and she was in
the back shooting people yeah because to
me I I feel like they always put
situations and stuff where it's like
it's like that it's like a fast in the
Furious kind of situation ironically
someone put that in there where this
stuff can happen but it's very very
unlikely you know what I'm saying he
said Money Train Anaconda Selena come on
King Don
watch this movie and tell me if those
movies don't compare to this movie and I
I would actually I know I'm I'm
but you know jumping it I give it a four
four popcorn like we have four it was
good I liked it I really liked it I felt
like a lot of the scenarios made sense I
felt like you know they oh okay so
clearly this was like
a a story about her
and the individual in there and I felt
like even though that that was the
highlight of the story they never made
it the prime like exact example like it
was always it was always this is a story
about her protecting this individual but
it never went too far about that
situation yeah it was never like the
goal
um I give it three popcorn there was too
many plot holes uh in it like okay when
her and and and goes gets to uh Cuba and
um they get into that bar fight type of
thing
and she's chasing the tarantula and
um if you notice it the scene she goes
in one door
she she cuts in one door and ghost goes
around the back ghost shows up when he
shows up literally just been a couple of
seconds he shows up his whole face is
scratched up like he's been in a huge
fight we didn't know that he wasn't a
huge fight but that's what his face
looks like and then you know he's
fighting he turns around he's fighting
and my wife laughs at me because he gets
stabbed in his shoulder blade right
right in the back right right here in
the back
first of all you stab me in the shoulder
blade fights over I don't care what the
hell we doing you stab me in the show
that's a moving part people that's a
moving part this is this is the part
that moves that arm is dead but this guy
goes running down the block at least 20
miles catching up to this guy that was
all coke uh running through the whole
Columbia I mean Cuba uh nah um it was it
was just huge plot holes in certain
spots and and how did they notice of the
the lion in
Long Distance uh snowy areas that was a
plot hole
um how come uh the the wolf didn't
attack in the manner that it was
supposed to attack when the kids is
present
um that was a plot Hole uh how come it
it was just so many different plot holes
and then the antagonist in this and it
was two of them they were able to find
her at every turn she pops her head up
slightly every
I didn't like how just because she gave
her name they found her that fast like
just like that yeah like little things
like that I I feel you I guess the
reason I didn't hit it too much is
because I always felt like the movie
didn't highlight that stuff because
that's not what the movie was about you
know what I'm saying no no I know I know
it listen it's it's it gets three
popcorn for me
um I can feel that it was just certain
plot holes I just couldn't Overlook but
I do feel like this is one of her better
films
um opposed to that shotgun wedding crap
that I had you watching yeah
so next week I want you to watch this
movie what's that it is
this movie the one that was blurry as
hell
missing yes
okay it's kind of like um have you ever
seen unfiltered
nah it's like
like a website kind of movie where like
they're always uh
unfriended did you ever see that
um
I don't know I think that was the one
with the cell phone thing yeah it's it's
the kind of movie where it's like
they're always getting the the shots are
always like shots from a computer or
shots from a cell phone like I think I
think I saw that that won the unfriended
thing but go ahead yeah yeah so it's a
movie like that but I I it's a they kind
of took it like a unique way like normal
time it's like pair it's like uh some
kind of like entity
or it's like a hacking group doing
something you know what I'm saying but
this one
it is about her uh it has what's her
name from it uh I know Will Smith isn't
married to her but I feel like she was
in a movie with Will Smith let me see
you you know who I would talk if I said
her name missing Netflix what's this
chick's name she's a very popular
actress her name is uh Naya long Nia
Long Nia Long she's in it yeah Will
Smith was yeah that was his wife and one
of them I think it was in was it in Bad
Boys
but she so pretty much what it's about
is her uh you know she has a daughter
and she she has a you know a boyfriend
and they go to vacation to Colombia
and you know how it is typical teenage
daughter I'm doing things the way I want
to do things you should be an emergency
fund money because she sends her an
emergency fund body uh you know things
go wrong this is the money you use
instead of doing that she buys booze so
I'm like but
supposed to pick her up Saturday she
goes Saturday her mom never came home
and the movies is about her looking
to find her mom oh and she's using like
the internet she's going to like those
live camera
feeds trying to like fight like pieces
together that's where she I was the
whole time because the because they've
been sending her text the whole time
they've been there and then she finds
out that
um
but but there's a certain point where
they stop sending it but you know how
she's sitting there drinking she's not
noticing that they stop like she noticed
they didn't send it but she didn't
notice why like they're missing because
they're not sending it so all right so
just let me walk into it and see what I
see from it yes I I looked and we'll
talk about that next uh month but uh
yeah I had to go get my tablet because I
forgot what it was called because I I
just couldn't sleep last night that well
and I watched it uh so let's let's get
to the majority of the reason why I
would say people's hair is this white
man can't jump
uh you know what's funny is there wasn't
a whole lot of like marketing push
behind this because I didn't even know
this was out it was on Hulu
I just know it wasn't it it was it was
more it was more push
um about
um
what was that uh house party remake that
I got to see that somebody said it was
garbage yeah I I think it's out I don't
know it's on some streaming device
someplace I'm pretty sure we could find
it
pretty sure somebody said it's garbage
and you know I don't like nobody chew my
food for me so I'm going to chew that
steak and maybe that steak is trash but
but you're gonna find out if it's trash
not yeah
someone's not gonna tell you you're
gonna find it I don't care about any
bodies uh opinion I say I do but I I
I want to see it myself but on this film
I didn't really want to see this film
because I loved the first white man can
jump
and I went into this film with such a
bias man woody Harrison and Wesley
Snipes
um they made a cult classic a cult
classic
those two guys and um
and and to have a white man can't jump
to or remake to white man can't jump and
don't have them in it
at all yeah it could have been a cameo
or something like you know yeah man cool
if it was like this was down the line
and like um
because I can't remember like a whole
lot of the plot stick uh to white man
can't jump the original one it was just
a hustle film yeah so it would be cool
if like you don't have to the end
there's that dude that was hosting the
event if that would have been them
hosting the event exactly I mean it
could probably could anything those
people probably were out of their price
range like really probably so because
this did look like it was I didn't
really see any noticeable people in the
whole movie what's up what's up Zavala
yeah yeah yeah why is Avala gotta keep
you know yeah he's crazy as ever since
that man passed away it's like in every
movie he's passing away he gots to get
the guns so I'm like no Zavala no not
this not against avalor how many times I
got to see this guy disappear
um it's sad
this movie is very good for uh race
relations
uh I like how they how they picked that
right uh you know stereotypes and stuff
throughout the whole movie yes he was
sitting the white dude was like why
dude's like man I thought we said we
gonna stop doing the race and stuff what
you know he said you can say way more
stuff do you have a way
he's like I ain't saying that but you
know what you could say
like you could say a whole bunch of
stuff I can't say
um
oh it was good to see
a lot of people might need this film a
lot of people with anger issues not
knowing that you have anger issues you
might need to see this film uh and they
show you lying to your spouse on no
matter how small you may think it is
still lying to your spouse or lying to
people and
you know it was it was just a real
realistic look on
you could be very uh efficient in one
sector of your life you know with your
children but be very deficient in
another sector in your life with your
kids and it wasn't just a moment of
reflection are you arming your kids with
the tools that they're going to need to
handle life and not just a particular
aspect of life but just life in general
are you going to be real enough with
your children's that they're emotionally
stable uh handling life and we got a
chance to see uh people's motivations
and goals sometimes if uh the universe
or God whatever you believe in is
putting you in one area
and it's not working that way maybe you
might need to change your method up and
go into the area that you know God or
the universe whatever you believe in is
pushing you in and ultimately they they
made it to where they needed to go but
the journey getting there and this movie
takes them on that Journey even though
it's a small movie even though they fast
forward a lot of things to get to an end
it felt to me like a Disney movie to be
honest with you it felt like Disney
needed to pick this movie up and give it
a bigger budget to do what it needed to
do but without that big budget Hulu was
able to back it in enough to give it a
believable beginning middle and and and
after I shed it shed my bias of uh a
white man can't jump the first one I was
able to embrace this film for what it
was opposed to what it wasn't you know
I like how they gave
the main characters time to shine like
they had a beginning middle and into
their character development I I really
liked how they did that I feel like
this is a class of example is like if
you don't like this movie I understand
but is it that the movie's bad or is it
that you hold the original soul to a
high standard that you can't see a movie
be doing anything remotely different
than the way that movie was done
um you know I think both characters did
a fantastic job I felt like the old guy
I think this film is the first time I
felt like a kid get off my lawn type of
you know thing and I couldn't shed the
bias that I had until
almost towards the end the bias that I
had
towards
this movie because of how good Wesley
Snipes and how good Woody Harrelson was
or how good my memory thought it was
right I might go back and watch that
film and be like oh my God it was utter
garbage compared to this film right I
would be surprised if they try to reach
out to Wesley Snipes and Woody Harrison
but like they they knew that
they're like even though Wesley Snipes
is is all over an Echelon than he used
to be he's still him and and that dude
and will know they can walk up there and
be like yo we probably want half the
budget just us yeah yeah
I mean and you know Woody just did that
movie
um with the um the mentally uh
challenged children with the basketball
stuff
they're still capable actors it would
have been nice to at least get them to
do a cameo yeah you know it would be
cool if they could have like
one of uh
like they do they did like a pickup game
with them in like the in in the gym or
once like yeah
something oh Woody owns the gym and you
know you know how they could have done
it you know how they they did that one
where they're like we're gonna let you
pick our people yeah and they pick them
and it would have been even if they
didn't pick them if they were just in
the bleachers and they said yo and he's
like dude I ain't I'm too old for this
like yo the Dude tell me to do with the
shades didn't have you did that dude
with the shades if you touch them I'll
kill you
and don't touch my shades that dude had
me that he wasn't listening to anybody
he could shoot his butt off too
um it was it was the
I got to give it full popcorn I gotta
give it four popcorn did you because of
how about you know you know what I
really enjoyed when they uh when they
thought when the the white dude dunked
and he's like dude we all know white
dudes Kentucky
yeah it was it was fun I think I'd give
it a four too like you know I know a lot
of people the thing is like I ask you to
look at this with a clean perspective
and not filtered because of the original
one you know nothing people need to stop
looking at these like remakes that
they're taking away from the original
another giving a different perspective
of their newer audience and a younger
audience that's all they're doing yeah
you know but I just this is the first
time
I felt watching this film
like uh get off my lawn kids like this
is the first time and you know I usually
go into films with uh unbiased like or
with what whatever preconceived notions
that I do have going into the film it
doesn't cloud my emotions watching the
film but for some weird reason this
movie had me emotionally invested in the
older movie and I wasn't giving it a
chance in the beginning I just literally
kept putting up a block and I said yo I
gotta let this go this is not Wesley
Snipes is not going to show up you know
Woody Harrison is not going to show up
all right they're not going to be in
this film and you got to start looking
at these characters for what they're
going through and what they're trying to
bring to the screen what I like is they
gave them different things that they
were fighting for them in the original
ones they didn't just pick like the same
struggles like they should like look
like these people they they got
different skin color but they're going
through similar stuff like yeah they had
they had you know everybody goes through
their little Financial things
but you know stuff started hitting the
fan and then they had to rely on what
God gave them you know that Talent their
skill and that skill and that Talent
carried today and at the same time
there was a moral behind it you know you
can run from whatever your destiny is
but your destiny is going to find you
either you're gonna you know bend the
knee to your destiny Are You Gonna Keep
bucking up against it and what happens
man when when you do that you know
you're gonna run through a rough patch
in life and they both ran through rough
patches in this life because they did
not want to accept whatever the universe
kept telling them or whatever they
believe in okay so um
I think that's pretty much uh what goes
for the show uh now we are going to be
moving the show to patreon I think what
I'm going to do king uh what you don't
think how you thinking because you can
make it public on patreon I think we can
make this public on patreon that way
people are at least on the the page you
know what I'm saying once they they feel
it then they can be like you know what I
want more of the stuff behind this uh so
uh it won't be on the YouTube channel I
don't know if it'll be next week or the
week after because we're trying to focus
this YouTube channel on IOP stuff uh
we're trying to grow iops a brand uh I'm
going to to put this on you know uh on
that now I don't know if we're gonna
just you know rework how
how it is or we're going to keep it
exactly how it is going forward on there
but it's going to be one of those things
where you know you know if you you don't
have to be a member of the patreon uh
but you go over there you feel
comfortable after a certain amount of
time then you can just go ahead and sign
up because we do have a lot of content
over there and we're going to put more
up going forward uh but yeah King I want
you to watch that missing yeah I'm gonna
watch missing and there's another one I
want you to watch I just don't know the
name right now okay well you have to get
the one that I have to give you and I
and I'm going to figure that out um
today but I'm going to go watch the Fast
and the Furious because next week we
have uh Spider-Man into the Spidey verse
part two or whatever uh that's the you
know the Miles Morales joint that's
showing up um
and uh this week Wednesday so I want you
to watch unfriended dark web too
unfriended dark web so I thought I saw
that man it's about the dude who gets
the laptop
I think I saw that but anyway I'll take
it part two no I saw I saw it there's an
unfriended and then there's a second one
called Dark web okay I didn't see that
one yeah so I would rather you watch
that actually than missing uh you can
watch both of them because missing's a
little relatively new but I think you
would really like because unfriended is
a good movie unfriended dark web is is
kind of crazy like
um I'll definitely check it out I gotta
go see the Fast and the Furious though
yeah I wanna I wanted to see the George
Foreman film I wanted to see a couple of
films and I I didn't get a chance to see
uh the Evil Dead I wanted to see that so
you know my wife and I this Friday
definitely we're gonna go see um the The
Fast and the Furious and I try to at
least get in another movie you know
before this long weekend you know
because it's Memorial Day weekend and uh
it's gonna be a good weekend no
hopefully all right so uh you tell me
what movie you just hit it up to me on
Facebook and I got you I'll watch it but
I appreciate it for coming through we
had like a strong 40 something in here
like I said next week I don't know if
it'll be next week maybe the week after
uh it will be on the patreon but it will
be public so you don't have to pay for
the patreon but I I do feel that after a
couple weeks months of you watching it
over there uh because that that's my
goal at this point it's like you know yo
no you know what's going to be behind
the patreon what the Flash
oh flash yeah well see as ramilla see
the the base shot r r is going to be not
behind the wall yeah but I want uh but
the spoiler cats those are going to be
behind the wall yeah so yeah because it
gives you you see all the people talking
positive about the flash it's ridiculous
like well you know my boy uh Queen yo he
went to go see it yesterday
and he hit me up he lives in Vegas and
he was like I'm mad much and he sells me
to take it he's like boom shows me the
ticket I'm like yo
I said I'm so envious right now once it
come out
uh June 6th
okay man I'll be in
I'll be in uh L.A no that's something
I'll see it
and then I gotta go to plan y that
Saturday cause might just go watch it
that Wednesday yo I didn't put in my
Whatchamacallit for playing NYC I didn't
even get the the link
the former media uh um I don't know
we'll figure that out later but I
appreciate it for coming through here uh
we're gonna talk uh we'll see you next
week oh keep in mind attic show tomorrow
unfortunately it falls on the same time
as the PlayStation direct so the attic
show what time is the PlayStation
director I don't know uh it's the
Showcase is that five I think or four uh
so that will be reacting to uh the
addict show will be reacting to that and
then we will go straight into the
talking over it uh I'm not doing two
shows so I'm just combining them it's
like I did with the Nintendo Direct a
couple months ago uh I I don't got time
for all that so
an appearance of General King we don't
know but I'm gonna tell you right now if
that PlayStation showcase is not what
it's supposed to be we gonna hold the
line
so this is Lord addict and King and uh
Lord King David we will see you later
let me see if we can find someone to
send the the round to yo we got to start
sending everybody
um from the room the fun show right
after the funds isn't uh
on Sundays man oh yes Sundays but the
problem is he
most the time he's like like 20 30
minutes after our show I'm gonna send
you over there to CB Gray he's the
destiny YouTuber going there so I hope
he sent you guys probably don't care
about that but give